okay welcome everybody
this is these are the frankie lectures
in the humanities
at the whitney humanities center i'm
paul north
and the series is called the value of
marx's
capital it is a companion to an
undergraduate seminar
that i'm giving at yale and the students
are here in attendance or
will be and it's also in concert with
a new translation that's being done by
my colleague paul reiter at osu
and in addition we're calling a critical
student edition or critical reading
edition
in which i'm co-writing the notes
so we're exploring the book together and
before we start i need to
thank a few people the frankie lectures
are made possible by the generosity of
richard and barbara frankie
and are intended to present important
topics in the humanities
to a wide and general audience i would
like to thank alex kaplan the director
of the whitney humanities center for
making this possible
metaphysically possible for those who
made it
organizationally possible sandra malone
bowles and lyanna hirschfeld krillin
and for those meaning one person audrey
leake who's making it
technologically possible thank you
audrey thank you to everyone
we are going to start with our
presentation from our
speaker and then we will turn to the
audience for questions please hold your
questions
when i give you the signal you can start
putting them in the chat
and we'll go through them that way i
like to start with a quote from the
speaker so this is a quote from
a great book marx's temporalities from
2013
from a section on laws and tendencies
i'm going to read this quote
marx tried to delineate tendencies in
the same way that a painter begins to
paint the background before painting the
subjects of the picture
the historical tendencies are sketched
out in order better to give evidence of
the nature of the counter tendencies
by the middle of the 1860s at least marx
was decisively opposed to the quote
idolatry of the rigidity of laws in
history
unquote just as capitalism is not
digging its own grave by itself
equally communism is not an ontological
dimension already produced in capital
it is necessary rather to work in the
space of the difference between
law and tendency this is a quote from
our speaker massimiliano tomba
and i'm going to give the screen over to
my colleague paul ryder
to introduce him uh thanks paul
and uh massimoviano thank you so much
for being here
massimiliano tumba is a professor
of politics and also the history of
consciousness
at the university of california at santa
cruz and
the history of consciousness program is
such a wonderful thing
really a legendary program and
it's great that he's he's there he is
the author of a number of books on on
marks and other topics most recently
a book entitled titled insurgent
universality
an alternative legacy of modernity
published in 2019
paul mentioned his marxist temporalities
book
which was published in 2013 he's also
written the book about
kant and benjamin and a book on
bruno bowers political categories
he a lot of his thinking turns on uh
temporality historiography time in
in marx and he has a number of articles
that that deal with
with those topics uh i hope that this
has suggested um something about how
broadly interested he is in marx and how
open
his scholarship is a lot a lot of people
we were talking about this earlier
uh paul and i and massimiano how a lot
of people
uh claim that uh they have
they are interested in really opening
things up now in this
era of post-sectarian marxist criticism
and yet
they cling mostly to a certain
idea perspective way of reading and
there's there is a real openness in
millian massimiliano's scholarship
that i i certainly appreciate a great
deal
so thank you so much for being part of
this mason liano uh it's great to
meet you and and to have you here the
title of
the presentation today is nothing to
expect but at tanning
bodies at work
thank you thank you so much for inviting
me
and i wanna i want to start
with the two anecdotes
one is a personal and
it concerns my youth when i was a 14
my my father basically sent me
during the summer sent me to work in a
in a small
factory in my in my village
and after a couple of days
i was there i was uh looking at
my watch because uh it was uh 4
30 almost 5 p.m at 5 p.m
is the working day is over i was looking
for that
time and then another worker
a colleague uh looked at me
and he told me what are you doing
put your watch back into your pocket
if the boss sees you that you are
looking at your watch it starts
screaming like crazy
oh wow that was my second day and i was
14. and the second the second
anecdote uh is
is about another guy uh whose name is
luciano and and once he
had to introduce himself and he
he was a real factory worker so for me
was just
the experience of one some one summer
and he introduced himself by saying
i have worked for 30 years
in that factory then he's uh
he's silent himself i just i think
the life is not just the sake of sorry
i'm very sorry for that um
and and yeah and then and then he said
uh
actually actually it's not that i worked
actually he said i have been
worked for 30 years
so why did i start with
these two anecdotes because
the first one it assures me
at that time i couldn't understand
exactly what
was going on but the first time about
looking
at my watch it shows me
what that the time when you are in a
factory time
doesn't belong to you
and and the second example
the second annie thought
the body that
has been worked
it shows that even the body maybe
doesn't belong
to you so when you are
a factory worker you
you sell your labor power
but unfortunately for you your body
is attached to that commodity labor
power
and and at that point even the body
is not really yours
you have to be subjected to a very
specific
discipline and not only is
very often you have to be subjected to a
kind of a
very obnoxious labor
that really consume
your your body
in the but in that second example there
is even something more
because in the transition from i have
worked into i have been
worked i see the transition from
active to passive
and the passive form that is very
present
in in capital volume one
is very tricky because immediately
immediately forces us to think
whose agency is that when i say
i have been who is the agent
who whose agency is there
so and this is the starting point of my
of my presentation i wanna i want to
share my screen with you
so when max
wants to describe or to
point out this agent
he uses gothic images
in these cases is dante
uh and and is the
is the hell is the infernal and
and marx cites dante
and he writes
i want to be from my
yeah he writes
with a working day ranging from 12
to 14 or 15 hours night
labor irregular meal times
and meals mostly taken
in the work rooms themselves pestilent
with the phosphorus dante
would have found the worst orders
and is inferno surpassed in this
industry this is how it presents
the factory as a as a hell as an inferno
and then as i say we move into
these gothic images
my question is i want to repeat my
question
whose agency is that who is the agent
of i have been worked
and marx
describes the capit capital
as a as a data label
which vampire like lives
only by sucking living labor
marx read polidori this book that was
published in
1819 and he uses the image of the
vampire
many many times for example another
citation
the vampire thirst for the living blood
of
labor or again the vampire
will not let the worker
go while there remains a
single muscle or drop of blood
to be exploited so the language is very
is very physical corporeal
muscle blood
and and and in capital
is described as a vampire
sometimes marxist uses a different image
it's not the vampire but is the werewolf
and uh and max is talking about
the werewolf like the werewolf werewolf
hunger for surplus
labor he also
describes the factory and the condition
of
labor in the capitalist mode of
production
as the torture of a sisyphus
other images this is again
it's not dante but in dante you can find
this uh
torture of sisyphus as a form of a
punishment
again another image that the max
use i'm just going through all these
different
images another image that marx uses
is the uh juggernaut
uh and he writes the juggernaut wheels
of a capital
and this is a juggernaut this
car is a kind of a huge wagon bearing
an image of an hindu god
the term juggernaut was also used in in
literature for example
uh it was used to describe
the character of a mr height
in dr jekyll and mr hyde
marx read all these kind of
novels and he used
all of them to describe or to give
some images other
of the capitalist mode of production
um
he also another citation now in order to
i want to go deeper in
in marx considerations of these
bodies at work marx is
describes the factory in terms of
in the bodies of the workers in terms of
say i i quote physical and mental
degradation
is talking about the torture of overwork
he also
writes that the factory work
exhausts the nervous system of the
worker and confiscates
every atom of a freedom
both in bodily and
in intellectual activity i think
i think this is important so marx is
aware that labor
is consuming both
the body and the soul your body
and your intel intellect
and now now the question is
why is marx using all these
images what does he want to provoke
one can say ah is that in order to
provoke a kind of a
moral indignation
i'm not sure about that maybe a little
but not
really in my opinion why because
max doesn't represent
the capitalist i always say so far
capitalist mode of production or capital
marx doesn't represent the capitalist
as an evil monster
actually in the in the
in the preface of the capital volume 1
when it is talking about the capitalist
he says that he considers the capitalist
a personified category
when marx uses the term monster
and he uses the term
he uses this term in order to describe
the capitalist
machine or
yeah the machine
which marks portrayed as
i called a mechanical monster whose
body fills
the old factory and whose
demonic power
burst forth in the fast and feverish
way of his countless working
organs
so the the monster is the mechanical
monster that marx describes also
as a body whose organs
are the workers
and there is a power and marx describes
this
power as a demonic power
so it's interesting the fact that he
uses all these
images there's a concept
evil monster
demonic in order to describe
machinery and not in order
to describe the capitalist
as a person as a subject
for that reason i don't think there is a
or yes is there but it's not a central
uh there is not real
more condemnation of the capitalist mode
of production
there is something more except we have
to go a little bit
deeper to see what is at stake
in in capital volume 1.
so the capitalist is not an evil agent
just in order to provoke a little bit of
discussion
i am not sure that the marx
would have shared some of the
moral condemnation on the one percent
that was very common and is still common
in in in in occupy
he would have agreed for sure with a
political and social motivation
but maybe not with the uh with the with
the moralistic
language maybe it's a it's a just
something that we can discuss later
because as i say for max the capital
capitalist
is a is a is a personified category
the agency that was our first question
whose agency is that when we are talking
about
i have been worked
in the agency is according to marx
either or the subject is
in marx is the automatic subject this is
a
mark's term and what is the automatic
subject is a value
is a process is a polarization of a
value
very quickly what is the valorization of
value
what is the process of valorization i
can only
we can we can go back in the in the in
the discussion if you want
the only thing i want to say is uh
that when we are talking about uh
valorization
the the crucial category or concept
is is time and that was my second
my first anecdote the second was a body
the first one was a time the central
concept is
time so basically for max value is a
is a socially necessary labor time
objectified
in you know one commodity but
what does it mean it means that the
value is not
the time that you usually
you you actually require in order to
produce a certain commodity
one capitalist maybe
needs three hours in order to produce
this span
another capitalist because of it has
machines
it can produce the same pen in one hour
mark's point is the value
is exactly the same because the value
is socially necessary labor time
objectified in the commodity so a kind
of an average
and and this is interesting because
because
because it allows us to
understand a very interesting phenomenon
again we can talk about that in the
in the in the discussion so but the
phenomenon
is how different capitals
work in the global market and in
competition with each other
so in a certain way for a capital that
is uh
extremely or can use
labor that is extremely productive
because it has machine it can produce
things
one pain in one hour but in order to
have this advantage
the advantage is it can produce things
faster
quicker than the socially necessary
labor time
what is necessary is that the in the
entire society
there are other capitalists which
cannot use machine
or maybe they can but they don't have
the money
to buy the machine so capitalism
is not an homogeneous system capitalism
requires differences in productivity
and and and these differences
are necessary in order to gain
and realize what marks cause
extra surplus value so in a certain way
my point is if you want to understand
i'm working in california if you want to
understand the silicon valley
you need to understand foxconn
in china you need to understand
how these two systems are connected
are part of the same configuration
how high-tech techno out high-tech
production is combined with the gigantic
factories in which you have a thousand
and thousands of workers
and i think marx allows us to understand
this kind of a relationship
that is i think very crucial today
because otherwise
the risk is to think
and this is my last provocation for the
discussion otherwise the risk is that
think
that automation can
get rid of human labor
i think it's not the case why because
capital
requires differences in productivity
capital is allergic to the
what marx called the generalization
of a technological innovation
we can talk about that
um then there is another dimension that
is important to
emphasize in uh in the process of
evaluation
so one is time and the other one is
that is a process is limitless
it doesn't have boundaries
so that means
and i'm going back to my topic
about this so that means
that
we can say that the capitalist mode of
production is characterized
by attention by a conflict
between limit and
limitless limitless is
the process of valorization
as marx defined it what is the limit
the limit is a that
workers have only one body
the body is is a kind of a limit
for the capitalist mode of production
and not only bodies but marx is
also soil and nature
so if there is a reason why capitalism
or the capitalist mode of production
is so destructive it's not because the
capitalist
is evil capitalism
or the model of the capitalist mode of
production is so destructive
because is limitless
okay now it's time to go back to our
chapters and uh there is a timer
in in this light went off again we think
there we go yeah and i don't know how to
deactivate his time it's not my office
um i was saying yes we can go back to
chapter four five six
and maybe i have to speed up a little
bit
um
so chapter four five six
are three chapters three distinguished
chapters only in the english edition for
some reason
uh in the german edition is one big
chapter
actually in the first edition 1866
67
is a is the is the is the
it's a long second chapter
because even the first part was not
divided in chapters so
what we call four five six as a chapters
is just one piece
and in the in the 1890
edition is the same uh what you can see
is a is the second part that is divided
in in paragraphs that is one chapter
chapter four
and not four five six chapter
five fifth
fifth test capital is uh is uh
is uh is what in the english edition
is a chapter seven okay
why is this important
uh it's important only for one
reason that you have to read
and you have to
consider these
four three chapters as one piece like a
theatrical piece
there is a beginning there is something
in the middle there is something at the
end but not the three chapters
is that one big piece
is a long chapter and in the beginning
is uh
the first pages of this uh
long chapter is a
the circulation of commodities
marx writes every day every day the same
story
is played out before our
eyes on the stage
what we can find there this is marx
again
are economic dramatis persona
masks it use it uses the latin and then
you will see this a term will come back
at the very at the very end of this
long chapter what you
can find on the stage is a buyer
and the seller basically what you can
find is a
equal formally equal and juridical
subject
and
and and when max introduces the
capitalist
is very coherent with what he said in
the preface he says
the capitalist
i quote is a person or rather
is a pocket it's something that the
functions
as functions as a capitalist
is a capital personified
and and this is what we can see on the
stage
you have to image this stage in which
you have a seller and buyers
and they sell and buy commodities and
labor power is
just one commodity amongst others
but then his problem is uh
okay where
value is produced
and then in the middle literally in the
middle
of this long chapter marx
writes something must take
place in the background which
is not visible in the circulation
itself
polarization and the creation of value
so the first dimension is the
the stage the appearance something that
is played out before our eyes
denmark introduces a second layer
something must take place
in the background that is not visible
and now at the very end of this chapter
he abandons the surface
the sphere where buyers and sellers
buy and sell their commodities
where they buy and sell
labor power and this
is the sphere of the circulation that
marx describes as a
i quote in full view of
everyone and of course
but at the very end the last page of
this longer chapter
marks a move into the
hidden abode of production
and he writes
when we leave this sphere of a simple
circulation
or the exchange of commodities
which provides the free trader
vergaris which is abuse
its concept and the standard by which it
judges
the society of capital and wage labor a
certain
change takes place
or so it appears in the physiology of
our
dramatis persona he began with a
dramatic persona
on the stage circulation formally free
and equal subject
but now he says a certain a certain
change
takes place in the physiology of this
dramatist persona
these masks these characters these
actors
he who was previously the money
owner now strikes out in front
as a capitalist the possessor of labor
power
follows as his worker the one
smarts self-importantly and is intent on
business the capitalist the other
the worker is timid and holds back
like someone who has brought his
own height to market and now
has nothing else to expect but attanning
i think this is a powerful ending
and
in the game the structure of this book
is really important because
if a chapter one two three
are about commodity
abstract labor fatigue
money then you we have
this a part two chapter four five six
one chapter in which we can see that
the transition from circulation into
production
and then we have part
three and four in which basically we see
human beings with their bodies
into the
hidden abode of production
and you see how value is produced
and how these bodies
suffer because of that condition
if you want we can make a short break
or i can i can go ahead it's up to you
uh i have a other i don't know something
like
either 15 minutes maybe or maybe less
uh but it's up to you no i think it's
fine why don't you go ahead
okay so
as i say at the end of this chapter the
discourse
becomes extremely concrete
it's no longer about abstract categories
marx needs it history
marx needs a lot of
footnotes and citations from the factory
report
he has to show how this system works
and and as i say that this course is not
just about the value as abstract
category
is a is about
com and it's not about a commodity
as a something abstract as a just
exchange
value marx is interested
in what a calls a special commodity
in germany is a specificity
there is a special commodity
and this special commodity is the worker
it is a special i would say for two
reasons
one is because labor power
is the commodity that can valorize value
if we know this story but it's a special
because is the only commodity that is
attached to
what max calls a living
body le bendiger
like english kite so labor power
exists only in workers
and the labor power is a this aggregate
of the mental
and physical capabilities
which exist i'm citing marx
in the physical form the living
personality
of a human being
so i think this is a this is a crucial
for many different reasons
and and it is crucial for what i said
before
if if the valorization process
is limitless and marx actually defines
this process as a limitless in chapter
three
before this theatrical
transition into the production so
if valorization is limitless the point
is
if we want to address a critique of the
capitalist mode of production
we should find what is the limit of
this limitless system
or structure or process
so the critique is in the tension
between
limit and limitless
and i think that tension
makes the entire project we can discuss
about that
that that tension makes the project
possible the project of a
capital volume one as subtitled
a critique of a political economy
so from from from
from that perspective
what we can see is uh
that the image we had on the
stage at the level of circulation
is false the sellers and the buyers
are no longer judicial persons
are no longer free and equals now they
are workers
in the in the in in in the in the
process of
production and they are not equal there
is a huge
asymmetries in the production we will
see these asymmetries in the in a second
and uh
and and the second thing is what is
exactly what they said is a
a is the tension between limit and
limitless
this is an other citation
i think it's the last one
and this is from the end the last page
of the chapter on the working day
and you can see something similar marx
is saying now
yeah it must be
a knowledge that our worker emerged
from the process of a production looking
differently
from when he entered
the contract by which he sold his labor
power to the capitalist approved
in black and white so to speak that he
was
free to dis that he was
free to dispose of himself but
when the transaction was concluded
it was discovered that it was not
free agent that the period of time
of which is free to seal is a labor
power is the period of time
for which is forced to sell it
that in fact the vampire
will not let go while there remains
a single muscle drop of
blood to be exploited
so what do we call freedom at the level
of a
juridical subjects formal
equality formal freedom
laws is no longer freedom when we take a
look
at these workers in the pro within the
production
so at least there are two concepts of
freedom
not only there is something even more
but it's
not possible at the level of a
circulation
the fact that this juridical freedom
legal freedom is actually not freedom
this contradiction this negation of the
juridical freedom is only visible
from the perspective of production
so for that reason this movement
from circulation into production is
necessary
in order to dis unveil unveil
the mystification that takes place
at the level of circulation
and if we emphasize a little bit to the
term unveil
we can say that the unveil
is just a translation of the greek
term aletheia that means
unveil is that the production is the
truth
of the entire mode of production
capitalist mode of production because
it shows that what happens at the level
of the circulation is force
and it shows something more that is not
visible
from the perspective of the circulation
from the perspective of circulation you
see equality and freedom you don't see
the asymmetry
and the destruction of bodies
i think i think if this is the reason
why uh
mark's perspective on workers bodies is
a kind of uh
is is is a key is is crucial
in order to address is materialist
historiography or
maybe in order to develop a
materialistic choreography
um for that reason it goes you know
into as i said before into the factory
reports
the archive on workers bodies
and not only archives
of sufferance but also archive in which
we can find
workers resistance why resistance is
possible or even necessary
as i said because this is this is the
clash
this is the tension between limit at the
limitless
if the capitalist mode of production
doesn't encounter
any limit it's just pure destruction
maybe even self-destruction something
that we can discuss
so going back uh
to the gothic uh imaginary
uh the term monster
uh occurs another time one more time
in in in capital but now
it did not deduct the worker
that marx described as
converted into a crippled
monstrosity by the manufacturer
the term monstrosity is is not really a
right transplantation because
the german term is either abnormal
so the worker becomes something abnormal
and for that reason marx uses terms like
industrial pathology physical
deterioration moral degradation
degradation
intellectual degeneration process
of distraction this is the terminology
again i want to emphasize i want to be
very clear about that
not because the capital is evil
but because the process is limitless
and
and we have to think one something about
this uh
character being limitless of the capital
maybe for the discussion uh
because maybe exactly in the fact that
for the that capital is limitless there
is something
quiet attractive in the capitalist mode
of production
something that i think we should discuss
so
i say that the capital
has been written thanks or because
of the workers resistance
so we have a question to conclude this
is now the real
really the conclusion what is what is
resistance and how resistance
work so if we
focus on on bodies we have to say
first that the body is something
extremely
individual we can have
we can share ideas we can share opinions
but this is my body
then the capitalist mode of production
is a the cause of our
share the condition
why because the capitalist mode of
production
converts workers
body into a monstrosity
into organ of the machine as a monster
so we share
something that i would call is a kind of
a common condition of
exploitation or you can call it a kind
of a
negative universality we all are
exploited we all suffer but my emphasis
is on
this negative universality
and i don't think we can do so
much with a negative or universality
but again that
this can be part of our discussion
because why because there is a third
level
and the third level is uh that there is
something
more there is another form of being in
common
and maybe there is a link between
the uniqueness of individual bodies and
something collective something that we
can describe as a social body
marx doesn't use the term social body
marx uses the term
capitalist cooperation when it has to
describe
how workers have been put together
in a factory and he uses the term
associated
associations when he describes
a different form of
associations of of workers therefore i
don't want to use the term
self-organization
our workers uh
have a different form of
being together i want to explain that
because in in what what we can call a
kind of a common collective social body
uh we can see something more what the
what the workers
share is not just the
common condition of being exploited
they share experiences culture
traditions even the past
sometimes so in a certain way the social
body can be read
can be read as a the result of a double
process
i use again modern terms that
you don't find in marks the result of a
double process
of this objectivation and this
objectivation
and this is my really last citation
kind of an ethnography of this
association
and
here marx is describing
the associations of workers in
in in france
what what is important what is crucial
in this
in this citation
is a is that
the togetherness the being together
becomes an end the association
is not instrumental these artisans this
worker do not associate
because they have to achieve an external
goal
yes also because of that
but in the process
of associations they
enjoy a alternative a different
form of togetherness
that becomes the goal
that becomes the end in itself and not
the means to another end i think
i think in my opinion this is uh this is
a
crucial and and
and i think uh is important for two
reasons
first because uh what i
called this double process of this
objectivation
and resubjectivation is a is just
an expression or is the practice of
association it's not a theory we can ask
why does marx and not to describe
socialism or communism in the book
because because this is not a theory
there is no theory of socialism there is
no theory
of another form of being together
or togetherness there is not a theory
this is a practice and marx is humble
enough
i don't think it was very humble but in
any case is humble enough
to acknowledge that in that case
workers artisans they are one step ahead
they they they are theory in action
they show us what
this different form of togetherness
looks like
and and and where is this citation from
where is this quote from this is from
the
manuscript when marx went to france
1844. so he had oh oh this is from the
economic and philosophy
yeah yeah yeah so
uh i wanted to end it with this citation
um because uh because uh
because i i want to end by saying
that uh the politics in this book or
maybe the politics
we need today and we can extract for
this book
it's not just a politics of
an anti what i call that is a negative
universality
there is something more and there is a
kind of
anticipation of the different forms of a
sociality
and in a certain way marx took this
perspective
bob of of exploitation but also
the way workers organize themselves and
they are able
to reinvent forms of sociality
as an anticipation of an alternative
and and and this is actually the
strategic
viewpoint that we should
adopt in order to reconsider
a critique of the capitalist model
of production that's it
thank you so much this is the time where
there's thunderous applause
i like to mention it would be here
um we thank you very much for
watching i wanna um
we're gonna open up to questions so if
folks want to put their questions
in the chat we will get to them i'm
going to start with a
question i have a lot
of them but maybe i'll ask you um in
your reading of capital
where does the limitlessness of capital
come from
is that a kind of fiction it proceeds
under is it a matter of law the reason i
quoted your
quote on law is because you you never
let people
you never let marx um become dogmatic
even himself and i appreciate that
about you but you could read him as
quite dogmatic that limitlessness
arises from the composition of capital
or arises from comp
competition necessary competition it's
unstoppable
until the whole thing falls apart
if ever if that's you know or the planet
falls apart
so where do you think limitlessness
comes from and do you see the
these limits the workers body there's
other that he names right the working
day
the organic composition of
capital how do they
stop being enabling limits let's say
of capitals drive and how do they start
being resisting limits
yeah i i would say this is my
understanding
so the limitless in the book in the text
it comes up when max describes the
process
of the money commodity money first
so is a process in which basically the
the aim of the entire process of
production
is to valorize value and to gain more
value
than the amount of value that you put in
the process
uh yes then you have
you have a first implication of that
that basically
the the use value of the commodities
you produce if if in a certain way
indifferent what you need in max terms
is a you need a better trigger
of exchange value
this is the only thing you need so the a
capital
or a capitalist in this case can
produce books or or
gans is exactly the same the point is
you need a commodity in which value is
objectified
and then you can sell these commodities
in order to realize
more value and so on so the the use
value
becomes kind of an abstract in the three
first chapters then you have a decent
process that they suggest
uh a a process of of uh
of uh is limitless because the only
end is to increase the value more and
more and more and more
but then this is the thing then
you have a very specific use value is a
used values
are indifferent at the level of the
commodities
there is a special commodity whose use
value
is not indifferent and this is the
worker
unfortunately for the capitalist when
you buy
labor power you have the worker of this
worker
yes you have the body of this worker
unfortunately for the capitalist why
because this commodity
can resist this commodity
is turbulent this commodity doesn't love
to be exploited
this commodity can make
trouble and and this is where the story
begins in my opinion so it begins at the
level of
use values are abstract
with the exception of one use value
that is the worker that is not abstract
and constitutes attention
with the with the process of evaluation
so you can squeeze almost everything but
you can squeeze
a human being only to a certain point
okay that's really great thank you um
let's
open it up the chat here and we'll ask
to unmute there's a comment from philip
voloshteter mark says that capital turns
every limit into a barrier
i'll just read that out but then there
are uh
let's see there's a question okay
there's mostly comments
here would people like to make their
comments
terrell would you like to make your
comment why don't we unmute
professor carver
if you don't mind
ah okay um no that's fine happy to
comment i'm sorry i got started
writing a lecture because there was a
little discussion going on here about
limits
and values and how that works out in
capital so um i very much created the
lecture and the discussion of
imagery and the theatrical um
analogies and personifications that are
going on i think that's very very
helpful the particular discussion
was uh about why capital should go on
forever because that's kind of the
notion that you put out and i think
marx's angle on that
is that
a value is set up to be something very
abstract and
purely mathematical uh in a certain
aspect
um so it's an abstract representation of
something that actually exists
concretely since it's abstract and since
it's particularly
quantitative mathematical in fact purely
quantitative uh mathematically
abstract abstract aspect
it's um limitless going to go on forever
so anything that seems to be a limit or
a
barrier is going to be
uh translate um uh
got over with um via
the um limitlessness of abstraction so
this this is you know
i mean borrowing off of hagel's logic
and
you can get at the same place with
derrida really that is concept
so imply the opposites they're defined
by the
others so uh anything contains its
opposite so
if you work abstractly obviously
everything goes around and around like
that
marx is i think really saying that
we've trapped ourselves um through the
commodity pricing uh value system into
something that makes us
chase abstract um
quantification and quantification is
increasing without limited
uh without limits so i think it's set up
that way it's very powerful it ties into
the discussion about
the uh the monster machine and all the
other kind of
un unstoppable desires that
he focused on that kind of imagery
thank you um thank you
yeah i i think
when when if we consider
value as as a as
abstract and uh
i think in the first as i said before
yeah the first implication of that is
that uh
the use value as i said becomes a kind
of a
you know simple barrier of of a value
and uh in the in the in
and the implication of that is uh
that basically the process of evaluation
is uh indifferent to
needs to
uh
the limitless of the natural resources
so
everything becomes a kind of a
limit that is external to that process
so
the point is in itself
capital is a kind of a mechanism
of of the self-destruction but
because there are so many limits
it doesn't destroy itself it doesn't
like
capital doesn't like the fact that there
are limits
but at the same time the fact that there
are limits
makes the makes the capitalist mode of
production extremely
dynamic it has to adjust the existence
of
limit for example marx writes
when there is a strike
the capital's answer is a new machine
maybe it's not a cause of fact reaction
but
is a way that capital likes to replace
workers with the machine but then it
increases
productivity and then it has other
problems but
yes i think we have just to consider the
fact that the capitalist mode of
production
is extremely flexible extremely dynamic
and for that reason
it can last for a very long
time what is maybe
maybe what is the last limit that the
capital
is a facing now maybe it's a climate
change
capital can really go
so far that he can destroy it can
destroy the planet
but that is not an happy ending
right not for anybody no okay we have a
question from
a kind of comment question from michael
paulsford michael if you would be
willing to restate it we'll open you up
yeah sure thank you um and look it's uh
i'm not trying to be annoying because i
don't um i kind of don't really care
about
the thing i value in marx is not the
moral critique but i guess
i was just um i'm trying to draw out
the the point you're making about evil
like the capitalist doesn't need to be
evil
you're saying that marx probably
wouldn't engage in a moral critique of
the one percent
and i just had a question about that i
guess like capital
a capitalist doesn't need to be able to
play their role it's irrelevant
like in the account in um well they
don't need to be evil in the sense of
wanting to produce suffering
but it seems to me that they do in the
sense of they need to be
indifferent to the suffering produced by
trying to get limitless value out of
limited things like human bodies
the person who ran the you know the
factory that your friend was worked in
for 30 years like needed to be
indifferent to the effect that it
the impact that that had on him does
that count as a kind of evil and to the
degree that the capitalist
is playing his personified capital
has to act in the interests of capital
um to that degree are they playing an
evil role
in the same way that an actor in a
production doesn't have to be able to
play an evil character
but within the theatrical framework
in this case in the in the framework of
production
they're doing something with evil
effects right
look i think thank you for your question
i think
i think we can easily say that capital
is maybe more cynical than evil
but it's not a question this is not the
point the point is that
uh that is not so useful
to use moral categories in order to
analyze or criticize
the capitalist mode of production i
think this is my point
why because uh because
because the implication is
okay then if we use a moral categorism
one can ask okay why don't we modalize
the capitalist mode of production
and marx would have said unfortunately
you cannot
and why because it doesn't depend
on the capitalist to do what is doing
is is in the game because of the
competition of capitals
in a certain way even the most brutal
capitalist
can even can even represent himself
as a good human being because he can say
or she can say
oh look at the list i
giving a job to all these people
that otherwise can start
i don't buy it but from a capitalist
perspective
you know a shitty job is better than no
job
and uh so this this is the thing and so
it's a is
i i think it's important to or i
say i follow max uh
in his understanding of the capitalist
model production without
moral categories because i think
uh is is uh is
a because i think it's it's not
it's just not possible to moralize the
system
this is the this is the political
implications another thing that
is important when we read this book is
that i think every single passage in
this book
has been written from the perspective of
the possible political implication
so marx is not just a scientist
that he gives us a
a representation of the capitalist model
production he's thinking
of the political implication of what
he's saying and what he's doing
and uh and and and i think yeah for that
reason
you know uh he
is not so politically useful to
attack the capitalist as an evil
agent i think that's really useful
i would add to that in your presentation
the picture of labor as losing its
agency
and the picture of capital is not really
the capitalist is not having any to
begin with
excludes morality which is a free act
of an agent that is not caught up in a
system like that
if you don't mind reading your question
this would be terrific
um hi
um so yeah thanks so much i've really i
actually didn't know about the chapters
being one chapter
um my question is when you talked about
like the body
and human being do you mean
ontologically or in recognition
of kind of a difference in toil that
bodies across
kind of the world or different
geographic areas take
and then more importantly than that can
we think kind of both of them together
in yeah just kind of can we fit them
both together
in a way
maybe maybe if i can say
it is an ontological dimension but
i don't like the term ontology so much
and i
i usually i avoid to use it
uh but yes i think it's at the level of
an ontology
but but i would put it differently i
would put it
in this way that
i can go back to that worker so luciano
when
when when a worker says i have
been worked maybe it's a
phenomenological more than ontological
what does it mean
when when you say i have been worked
what does it mean when you say after 30
years
my back hurt a lot i'm sick
and and so on what does it mean it means
that
the process of what marx would have
called a deterioration degradation of
your body
as
that process went through something that
is extremely
artificial not natural it's not
that your body hurts because hurts
because
you are getting old it's because
it has been consumed and then
you have a political a theoretical
implication so the consumption of
labor power is at the same time the
consumption
of your body and your soul and your
intellect and not because this is a an
extremely
hard factory work i think the same thing
happens in in in in
today with workers who have to
work at their computers for 10 hours a
day
what is the result at the end of the day
there are many many
uh inquiries interviews with the workers
who do this kind of job
at the end of the day the meaning is you
have a headache
your back earth and
what you want to do is to go to bed
so this is a kind of this what i'm
talking about
i suppose it's a kind of a phenomenology
of the body
that goes through this process
and i think the theoretical assumption
of that is again
is this attention this this conflict
between the limitless
process of evaluation and the fact that
we we we have to accept the fact that
the body
as is in the condition of finitude you
know
and what happens when you put together
the finitude of the body and the
limitless mode of production
this is this is my simple question
yeah that's a it's an important question
it does seem like the limitlessness is
not
it doesn't seem to sustain itself
without draining
the life out of finite lives
that's true okay i want to go to
i think one more question from liz
kinema liz do you want to
can we unmute you and you'll present
good thank you okay so
um it's kind of in paragraph form i'll
just read it out loud
um because of marx's references to
intellectual activity and mental
degradation
which kind of stood out to me in this
presentation
um in capital do you think it's fair to
say that he's always been talking about
what lazarato
and others would call immaterial labor
um
i'm just curious about your thoughts on
the on the fortist post-fortis
labor distinction and whether you think
immaterial labor being hegemonic
makes resistance more challenging
precisely because it takes place in the
psyche or the mind
yeah thank you for this question
so my problem with the the
expression is with the statement in
material labor
being a demonic is a is the term
a demonic and the endorse to the term
immaterial
when we're talking about the material
labor again there is something very
material
in the material labor
when we're talking about the internet or
communication
we are also talking about two things and
we're talking about
the the cables
under the oceans which make this system
possible and they are very material
and someone has to produce these things
and sometimes and someone has to place
these
cables under the oceans and
so there is a materiality in the
material in the immaterial labor but
this is
just the secondary critic my main
critique
is uh is that this is a very stagis
teleological understanding of the
capitalist mode of production
when you say oh this is agent money i
think yes maybe
it's a demonic in part of the us
part of europe canada but
there are three-fourths of the planet in
which
immaterial labor is not a germanic
so is even even in california
where you find silicon valley there is a
central valley
in which 800 000
workers are employed in agriculture
and they generate something like 54
billions of dollars
so the point is that is not that oh
agriculture is a residual
and silicon valley is a demonic or
as a negri trying to correct his point
is tendentially a demonic because some
people from
post-colonial studies criticized his
eurocentrism because
it's not a germanic in three-fourths of
the world then you can say oh yes but
it's a tendentially demonic
no i think i think the difficult the
difficult task
is to combine the two things i want i
want i want to read i want to see
a theory and i think marx is almost
there
that is able to combine silicon valley
and central valley agriculture and
software and how these two things work
together how these two things are
combined together so this is a
theoretical political
effort because otherwise
i think it's just a new version of a
teleological conception of history
and in the in the 20th century
industrial labor was the germanic and
agriculture was a backwards or residual
now
immaterial labor is a demonic and the
industrial labor is a receiver i don't
buy it
they these different forms of
exploitation co-exist
what do we have to explain is the
coexistence
not the fact that one is a demonic or
will be a germanic or it is a tendency
this is my i want to read marx without
teleology
and i think in a lot of
my italian fellows there is still
some teleology when they think
in terms of immaterial labor and what is
a tendency and so on
this is the time to mention again the
book on marx's temporalities which is
a crusade against a teleological reading
okay there's a couple of other um
questions one is a comment but why don't
we do these two and then we'll call it a
night
this is philip walsh dead or philip do
you want to
present your comment question
can you hear me uh yes okay hi max
greetings from red bay
um you know i'm very uh
taken uh with your focus on the body and
this
sense of how capitalism tie you become
an appendage of the
machine it formats your time
uh you know it's the focus that i see in
your work and postown and a lot of
different people
and it's a focus away from a mode of
attacking
capitalism which starts to establish
exploitation
by by trying to trot out quantities and
doing mathematical equations like
so many hours are stolen each day and
that seems to be right on the terrain
that neoclassical economists
love because it can end in some endless
dispute
but when we're focusing on what happens
to the body and the fact
that it's limitless and it never stops
it's going on and on which means you're
going to work
all your life and if there's a covet
plague in your home
and you risk dying they're going to push
you to get out
so you could work it seems to me that
that particular focus in mark
and it's all there in in this notion of
capital
as this kind of automatic mcm
prime generator that just keeps on going
and
uh yeah it doesn't really care about
your body it's the skin that has
labor power around it and if it could
extract that it would do it
but it's quite happy to work you to
death and have someone else so it seems
to me that your
your entire focus is a much more
effective organizing angle just in terms
of
trying to make people realize what
capitalism is
and what can't change about it you know
which is it precisely the limitlessness
this kind of faustian drive to keep
going
so you know it's more of a comment than
a question and an
encouragement saying as always i await
your next book max
now thank you phillip yeah
yeah yeah yeah you know especially after
i i published mark's temporalities
i had the opportunity to go back to marx
again and again
but uh it was more about you know what
is the political stake in this book how
we can
reread this book today politically
and and as i said and and i think it was
pretty clear
at the end of my presentation i think we
have a problem
and and the pro one we have many
problems
political problems and economic problems
but one of them is that that we think
politics
in terms of entity once i asked my
students
uh okay so you don't like the capitalist
model production
now what oh we have we want to
we want to abolish value
what does it mean i'm serious what does
it mean
oh we want to stop the valorization what
does it mean
i really don't know exactly what it
means
we don't want to produce commodities
yeah
why how so it's
it's a kind of so we we have a list of
things which
denote the the capitalist mode of
production and we think that
by attacking all these pieces
in the list of things we have something
else
i'm not sure about that i'm not sure
about that for that reason
my my conclusion was look i think
marx could write this book because
in the 19th century it could see
an alternative associations
how workers organize themselves how they
organize their own life in a different
way
so that was the positive thing it's not
only empty
they they had a kind of a prefiguration
anticipation you can call however
whatever you want
but they had an alternative in action
and that was a theory in practice
marx has only to develop the theory that
was
already embodied in their practices i
think today
we we should do something similar where
is now the anticipation of a different
form of life and we have to extract
theory from there instead of developing
a new theory of the anti
capitalist model production or
we the entire humanities should be
against the capitalist mode of
production because we are all exploited
does it work
without without without associations
without
real forms of a workers organ
does it work then then people start
dreaming oh but we need a party
okay sorry i become polemical uh i don't
want to be because
i i i agree with the with with the
philip otherwise people think i'm
disagreement with him i
i i agree with him but i think we have
open questions i think today we have a
much
more open questions than answers
and i think when we read this book
capital volume 1
we should define the questions more than
answers
i want to give a chance for alessandra
for natsari
to ask a final question can we
unmute alessandro
uh yeah hello hello um
so i had a question regarding the the
move from um
uh circulation to production that in the
chapters that you are
you are uh working through uh you know
we get this move from
leaving the sphere of circulation into
the the hidden abode the the
the promise that the secret is somehow
in the factory
um and i guess i'm wondering up to what
point do we need to relativize that
and i'm thinking is circulation
necessarily the sphere of mystification
and then if that's the case what do we
do with volume 2 which is
sort of an intensified return to the
sphere of circulation
yeah good question good question
um
please there is a an
elegant way to answer
and i borrow
maybe something from
tombasaurs who brought the book on
time and in mark's capital
one can say that there are three
layers not stages three layers of
analysis
in capital volume one marx is under is
trying to understand time at the level
of a production
how time is crucial in the valorization
process
but within production in the volume 2
is understanding how time
is dominating
is uh is is is a crucial
in the circulation and competition of
capitals
and then we have a capital volume
3 in which max marx combines
these two levels and basically he
he develops he really develops an idea
of a
competition of capitals and i think this
is very innovative
even for marx himself because
because because when when when when he
wrought
the grundris which are
i go back to a polemical point
which are basically the text that the
people
who are talking about in material labor
love in the grund risa you don't find
the competition of capital
marx is working mikhail island
that i think he will come to give a
paper if
he brought an article about that in the
grundrissa
marx is talking about capital in general
is very abstract
it's like there is only one capital
then in the 6163 he developed
his ideas and if he understood that
actually there is not
such a thing as a capital in general but
in general but there are many capitals
and then he has to address the real
issue of the competition among these
capitals
and this is and this is what makes
things extremely concrete
so my answer is a
we have to read these three books as a
three
level levels three layers of analysis
in which in a certain way you find the
the the
concrete analysis of
many capitals in the world market
in in the in the third volume
but it's just a you know it's a kind of
a way
to develop is his analysis
uh but then and then it's possible to go
further but then we go in philology
because it's also true that
max brought capital volume three before
volume one and there are many many
different issues and then
one can ask why did he stop writing
capital and then and some people say he
stopped writing
capital after the paris commune and then
he was more and more
interested in non-capitalist
foremost forms of society he started
reading a lot on
india and and the commune and the and
the common possession in the villages
on russia and the option and me he
started reading
history and the non-capitalist forms of
production why short answer because i
think
he had to understand what a
non-capitalistic society should look
like
and the second question how is possible
to
skip capitalism in society
which are not organized in a capitalist
mode of production
and that was a crucial question because
there were people who claimed to be
marxists
who thought already in the 19th century
that
it was necessary to go through every
single stage
and in order to achieve socialism first
you have to be a
a capitalist society and marxist was
was in doubt and in the in that a
beautiful letter
letter to berlin actually is not true
you can use the russian option just in
order to skip
the capitalist model production so
why i'm saying that i'm saying that just
in order to emphasize one point
the project is an open project
there is no way we can read this book
dogmatically
is an open project and i think today we
should find
questions more than answers
in in this book and
yeah this is what i think thank you so
much
that's really it's the first i think
hopeful presentation
on marx that i've ever heard and i can
see
a whole other text there so i really
appreciate that
opening up a set of
positions from which to critique
capitalists that don't
turn capitalism that don't turn it into
a big monolith you'd have to destroy all
at once
finding positions within it that are
already outside of it
i think that's really hopeful so i want
to thank you
on behalf of everyone who's here this is
another time where there would be plenty
of applause
you'll see them hands clapping and
um thanks again for coming thank you
thank you very much and thank you for
your comments and questions